so Luke Cage we have all seen it this is
spoiler warning now I'll sort of step
back from it because I've already put
out a video with some of my general
overall thoughts which I did not watch
because I didn't want to not to inform
our discussion done okay but I didn't
want you because I don't care took me
three episodes to get into the show fell
in love with luke cage liked him and
Jessica Jones loved him in this I think
Mike Colter is the reason to watch the
show along with a lot of other
incredible talent supporting him it was
and I can say this definitively it was
one of the first times I watched a lead
or TV show that has made me want to read
the comic I thought the first episode
was kind of weak and after that I start
getting into it and I felt like the
entire first episode I was waiting for
Luke to do something and it felt like it
the whole episode was just waiting for
him to act to do something to be that
hero and I felt like throughout the
series there were times when he backed
slide the back slit and had to be and I
felt like they were just times when you
need to just pick him up with a forklift
and drive him to the action so that you
would fight and do something be the hero
and it's interesting that how you say
that he's the thing to watch about this
cuz I'm not sure about that and I wonder
if and it's no it's not criticism
against the actor I like the actor I
like the way he embodies it he's got a
natural presence in this this charisma
this charm I do want to watch him but it
something there were times when I felt
like he wasn't they weren't giving him
the materials you need to be a leading
man and I felt so often like I was more
interested in the supporting cast and i
was a lot more interested in misty
knights classed as detective and that's
why Luke always needed a partner that's
why Claire temple the night nurse showed
up halfway through the season to serve a
beat saw me more because he's the type
of character who doesn't say anything he
doesn't tell you what's on his mind he's
not a her most talkative character what
I did like was all of the other things
the look
the shelter style the sound the music
the the blackness of this show I want a
lot for me right now this is my second
favorite of the Netflix series hmm i
think daredevil season 1 is my first
easy one to daredevil luke cage but they
know this is my least favorite necklace
hey oh it's on it is not so starting
with my culture talking Luke Cage yeah I
think if he had a weakness when he had
to get dramatic it tended to fall flat
what I loved him was what it was being
cheesy I love Luke Cage being cheesy and
I loved clay her pointing out every time
he was being Jeezy I love that that was
awesome um but I I thought it was fine
as a leading man almost all my issues
amash's are sort of several a but they
pretty much all orbit problems I have
with the villains none of which are
problems with performances my problem
with the first half when we're dealing
with cotton mouth boy who was a very
good character and a very good
performance yes but he never felt like a
threat to luke cage then cottonmouth
dies impossibly my favorite scene in the
entire show but then we got a
diamondback now diamondback got an
awesome initial intro showing up and
going can you dig it when he did that
I'm like I'm on board with this guy and
then everything that happened after that
like and I'm off I am no longer on board
with this guy I think the whole idea of
him being Luke's brother serves no
function whatsoever it has zero point
his motivations were ridiculous his
outfit at the end was stupid my problem
with the first half was the villains
while engaging characters weren't a
threat to him then in the second half we
get a care we get a villain who is a
threat to him but I didn't like as a
character I didn't have it for I I
wife's Diamondback I loved Eric lorae
hardees performance and almost the same
thing with Alfred winner as black Mariah
oh she was my favorite of the of the
three vil she
she was mine too but it was another
thing where I felt like they would bring
her to the edge and then they would pull
her back again and like after like the
the moment when she staff when she kills
cotton mouth and then she goes home and
she looks at the picture of her of Mabel
and sailor sees her own face
superimposed and I was like this is
great and it felt like by the next
episode they've forgotten about that yes
so I like you said I never had a problem
with the performance of the characters I
felt like sometimes there was just an
inconsistency and how the villains were
written I was ok with Diamondbacks
costume at the end just because it was a
little did look kind of saline it didn't
look like the one but I I understood the
function for and how it was supposed to
be this weird kind of modified suit that
gave him these powers yeah the I thought
that last episode was a little bit
weaker yeah and that fight didn't need
to be as long as it wasn't I do have
problems with this but I still there was
enough about it that I like that I'm
able to ignore some of those problems I
thought that the death of cottonmouth
was one of the highlights of the show I
also thought it happened too early maybe
in the season because it felt like the
Diamondback stuff was rushed because
they were trying to introduce a lot of
really big emotional notes with him yeah
that I was like we'll wait a minute wait
a minute they're like he knows him or he
doesn't know him and like what is going
on they have this connection and I'm
like hi I and they kept teasing him and
I'm like I I don't care like I want
cottonmouth back I would like I'm also
not sure how I feel about shades I
really like shake okay oh right like
Emma I liked him a lot I hated shades I
thought shades sucked the air out of
every scene he was in I thought his
performances were completely flat I
thought his costume was ridiculous most
of the time just one block his glasses I
think look Ryan I thought they were
stupid gimmick end that they didn't work
I thought shades was a fantastic
henchman I liked what he brought out of
other people and scenes that when he was
in with them I liked how when he was in
a room with cotton mouth cottonmouth got
on edge cuz he knew what that guy
represented I liked how when he was in
scenes with Mariah that he was teasing
out this this more
addictive night of stuff with my family
I don't say yes fantastic chemistry now
because he was being patronizing to her
the entire side yes and she called him
on it and I they had this weird turn
inverted Macbeth relationship where he's
almost the Lady Macbeth character where
he knows he knows he can't be the
figurehead she's in the position where
she can be the face and the name behind
their brand but he needs to convince her
that she needs to be evil if she needs
to get her hands dirty and bloody and he
needs to provoke her and manipulate her
into doing that and the gender reversal
from that dynamic just felt kind of
unusual to me and it was a usual but
that was part of why I liked it I took
both agreed neisseria I like that as we
so often I didn't like when they tried
to infuse some sort of sexual chemistry
in his attract attraction to her I
didn't need em like that that that was
unnecessary now here's something because
you sort of commented on the blackness
of the show overall and which I I'm not
going to disagree with you on it I think
he's a strength of the show but I think
my Owen cuz I don't know if you're aware
of this I'm not black so uh when clinic
but I feel like my ability to connect
with that aspect of it is hampered
someone for whatever reason you are able
to connect with that end because I mean
I've never really been into
blaxploitation movies and that and yeah
you don't have to be black to enjoy this
stuff but I've never sort of steeped
into that I'm not into rap I've never
that's never been in my world that's
never been something I've gravitated
towards so when I watched something like
this I can recognize that that stuff is
good but for me it doesn't paper over
the flaws and I feel like for you that
vibe was strong enough that it carried
over some issues that is not a criticism
of the show that is me explaining part
of why I personally call you he might
not have been the target on my phone I
fully accept that that whole aspect of
the show was not aimed at me and that's
fine it doesn't have to be no but I
think for that reason that might be part
of why I'm more critical of these things
some of which I mean you're not even are
with me our weaknesses but obviously
bothered me more than you I've always
loved Motown in a little bit i have a
little bit more of an appreciation of
hip-hop the the soul music that was
infused in the show i just i love that
and some of the blaxploitation elements
I yeah I did connect with those seeing
that in one of these shows are one of
these movies that we have not seen yet
was did feel like a breath of fresh air
and I was able to just appear Lee not
being from that world but adding up
Richard liking that enough that the
problems that i had with it bothered me
less because there were more elements
that i did enjoy that i did feel we're
done really well well i mean i think
that's true of most entertainment if if
something connects with you on an
emotional level you are going to be much
more willing to forgive you know the the
technical flaws absurd thing so i'll
just talk about my favorite episode if I
can love it this is all about me the
prison episode where I think the leg
spots to seagate yeah I really for some
reason I just really enjoyed that whole
sequence maybe it was just the beard
there was one scene where it walked in
him in like two seconds later you know
which one I really enjoyed a lot of sort
of that episode and go ahead now at
least favorite part I was born huh i was
really bored and somewhere in between i
was looking at the similarities and
differences between the comic book
origin and what was there some day there
were a couple of supporting roles that
we haven't talked about yet the big one
being misty knight who was her
phenomenal yes she's she's a character
that I've always liked I liked the in
the cast of misty night in cali knowing
who we got a teaser that Claire grabs
like a thing of ideas yeah like
self-defense training new Halloween she
is going to be an iron fist they wove
her that they've cast her I'm really
that like a misty man was the character
I was the most intrigued I had liked her
more than I like Luke I thought the
times when she blew up and she reacted
poorly or done well I thought they were
believable I like the one episode where
she's in the box with the shrink she was
phenomenal and
her chemistry with Luke was really
really good well and part of misty
knights story I was surprised how much I
liked your partner turf okay Franklin
yep I think I think a lot of that came
down to the performance now the moment I
recently switching see we're missing the
eye thing were you two around polarize
my age I enjoyed his performance again I
found his chemistry particularly with
misty was very good i thought they
played off each other very well I liked
the eventual backstory that we got to
him I like the sort of the unspoken
implication of he didn't become corrupt
because he's like a bad guy but because
he had no reason not to anymore when
when she tells the other crook cop when
she mentions how his son died oh yeah I
just found his gun when he yet secured I
love her line that scarf tells a lot of
jokes but he never smiles mm-hmm I was
like oh oh oh I wish you would tell me
that bottom before he died so there I
didn't like scarf a lot not even cuz he
was white I I didn't like the the energy
between the two of them I didn't think
they had any chemistry between MMSD um
but the but I'll back up a little bit I
did like him later um he grew on me as a
character and an actor and I want to
attributed to writing there were the
time to my felt like he but his dialogue
or his performance was coming off just a
little bit too stiff it it's like you
just yeah I like the character but again
maybe some of you it took me a couple
episodes to warm up to him cuz I just
felt like he and maybe was intentional
because he was the cop and he was
thought the outer you was white like he
didn't fit into this world he was kind
of rub brushing up against everybody
sort of clashing with them and maybe
that was intentional they were trying to
show that but it felt like he didn't
establish a rhythm with the rest of the
group until two episodes in maybe night
nurse um yeah yeah whoo and it's just
I'm so wonderful i was seeing rosario
Dawson in a movie
I was like oh that wasn't she's I given
in some bad movies but she has always a
highlight in whatever I've seen her in
and it they've given her something
different to do every time this is
revealed this is her fourth go around in
this world she always has a different
role but it always feels organic she is
one of the most genuine actors I've seen
I think I've seen working okay so
despite the fact that for a very long
time his comic book was Hero for Hire
did it bug anyone else how far out of
their way they went to be like no he
will never accept money and I'm like
that's kind of his thing you like well I
like how many times is he gonna turn
down people giving him but again I get
that they're doing the noble thing but
it's like are we ever going to get a
status quote where he is the hero for
hire because it seems like you're really
hammering that that will never be the
case I have a feeling that that will
change after the defenders presumed
assuming that he gets a second season or
something they might do some sort of
switch up but I have a feeling the
barber shop because it ends with fish a
maybe this place just shouldn't be a
barbershop I've a feeling that will be
retro converted into the private
investigation office or the home base of
Heroes for Hire which might be Luke
might be luke and I Rufus it might be
Jessica Jones she might like work if
they somehow work together to come back
there is a couple or something I have no
idea they will it might be misty night
and Colleen wing working together all of
these characters have sort of floated
around the Heroes for Hire title in the
comics mmm over the last one decade said
I have a feeling that location will
return as their base I don't know who
will occupy it loved the fall of um
called Fort Knox yes that timing
sequence that was that was the action
highlight and I think honestly it was
the only action thing that really work
because the the problem was part of it
was a lack of steaks because by and
large most of the action scenes he was
he just stood there until they were out
of bullets and then he beat people up
his assault on that building was
over-the-top enough to overcome that by
just going big um but then later even
when they had stuff that could hurt him
like oh well he
shot and then just stumbled a way all
right like I said aside from that one
which I did really like I was bored by
pretty much every other action saying
yeah I one of the Judas bullets to amp
up that I just never really understood
that he could be hurt but I don't know
once they were mass produced for the
cops did we ever see them go off we
don't were shocked if they did he's not
foolproof Zozo and is like you you had a
SWAT team worth of cops all holding
Chekhov's gun and not on them at all I
also I thought that was a weird
direction for the story to go in because
you've now taken the one thing he can do
right and now we can't do that so um
although I did love that scene with it
um I think it was Mariah cottonmouth
were talking and she was like does he
have gills damn look I'm gonna burn him
yeah that's like oh my god knows why
that was one of her great turns where
it's like oh my gosh she's like
somewhere underneath this this more
respectable veneer she is possibly even
more business than he oh and some of my
favorite scenes were actually the
flashbacks to her and come up as kids
growing up Mabel those are some of the
most she would she would grab the kid
him but slight snips as figure off with
what the preacher was everything
although I have to say that the Cameo
that I kept really really really really
wanting was like Idris Elba to just kind
of work I wouldn't need much just like
drinking coffee in the back well instead
they got Method Man doing oh thank god
if it did his own ready made up a new
rap for the show people look for flow
it's doing that scene I was like is that
a little bit i switch hoodies i love how
proud he is to have luke cage's shot up
hoodie and i love that becomes a thing
when people are getting the heart
what they're wearing these these blade
bullet-riddled hoodies as like a
merchandising item and it's making the
cops job harder look the first time he
said sweet Christmas I like oh yeah I'm
applauding I'm Amy said in a few too
many times after night and I think there
was actually it was an unfortunate
placement where I think he said it at
the end of one episode and then said
that again early in the beginning of the
very next episode is a bad idea when
you've been chatting right so I was like
so just but the fact that they came on
top of each other then it was like all
of a sudden I notice I'm like ok they're
over using it but I just kind of want to
like mention this as talking about the
character himself not necessarily a
specific to the show but I think the
show kind of pays homage to this is I've
always found the character as conceived
in the comics is sort of the black
captain america which is not to say that
his story is the same as Steve Rogers
story or that you put him in the
costuming he's the same type of
characters Kavner because he's not what
I've meant by that is that his story
sort of models the black experience in
America and that bait his origin is that
he was wrongfully incarcerated he was
taken away from his home putting Shane's
put in prison and then subjected to
these experiments more or less against
his will or with this understanding of
potential freedom he was mistreated and
then he is a fugitive who is hunter who
has to hide his identity and I think
that does speak two three four hundred
years of the black experience in this
country on a very very micro level so I
think I think this was a good show to
represent that and I think I mean at
comic-con the showrunner chilled Coker
said it better than anybody it's like
we've never needed a bulletproof black
man more than
right now now so I think just for the
cultural what this can do for for
society I think is really good I did it
I want to see more of this character i'm
looking forward to the next round I'm
certainly looking forward to the
character again again I liked him i'm
looking forward to defenders i'm i'm i'm
actually I'm more up for a second season
of this i am of jessica jones because i
feel like there are places to go with
him where is again I loved Jessica Jones
but that felt like such a finished story
right rude I did like it quite a bit and
I do want to see where they go from here
and I'm very excited for Luke Cage I'm
excited for him to be in the public
consciousness frankly so I think we will
wrap it up there um you guys got
anything to plug I know you always have
50,000 podcasts but Paul Paul you got
anything um you wanna do your podcast no
all right I've got a number of podcast
you can find them all on the fire and
water podcast at fire mono pod cast com
I am the lead writer and a comic book
called our middle of Justice armadillo
justice for rising sun comics and i'm
one of the writers and co-writers with
ryan gaily on red and green columns
which you can also find on rising sun
comics and i'm one of the co writers of
red and green comics which you can find
it rises i'm also the writer of my pet
ninja web series on rising something up
and I misspoke earlier it is the fire
and water podcast network that I am a
part of and while we're co-writers on
red and green it's actually call scooter
and Ryan Daley co-writers on Britain
until you read that issue and you
actually see that my name does come
first and really if you put in a mirror
though you can actually see it and I'm
the art director I spent a lot more time
working on up and Papas and thanks for
tuning in have a good
nice you can follow me on twitter aight
council of geeks check out the council
geek podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher you can also check out my new
podcast punch like a girl which is also
available on itunes stitcher that is a
separate feed and until next time this
council is adjourned Mike I'm yes test
Lily lick Lionel's lusty lovers let me
lick my toes lusti others tomorrow I'm
gonna put this at the end I hope you
realize